Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thanks everyone
that submitted questions for this week’s
Q&A.
It seemed like most of you agreed episode
4 was one of the best Korra episodes so far.
Lots of questions about Toph and Korra fighting
Kuvira so let’s get to it, careful for spoilers
if you haven’t seen the episode yet.
Question 1 - Gabriela asks, Do you think we’ll
see
more firelord this season?
Question 2 - Li Cheng asks, what happened
to the
Dai Li?
Question 3 - Momo Bear asks, will Toph reunite
with her daughters?
Question 4 - Darnell asks, if Korra is cut
off from her past lives, what’s the point
of regaining her ability to enter
the Avatar State?
Question 5 - Matthew asks, do you think the
drawing of Korra was Fan Art?
They said they really
like people’s fan art.
Question 6 - Fisherman asks, Do you think
we know Lin and Suyin’s fathers already
or do you think they’re completely
new characters?
Question 7 - Qyndox asks, now that Korra healed
herself, how will she confront Kuvira and
when will
she
change into her new outfit?
Question 8 - Supergamelord asks, do you think
any regular benders would ever be able to
bend more
than
one element?
Question 9 - Tanzir asks, do you think Kuvira
will try to take the swamp and use it to power
their new machines?
Question 10 - Shinobokage asks, what’s your
favorite last airbender episode?
Winner - Rachel Adria